c'est vraiment la nature qui reprend ses
droits la biodiversité qui est là quoi
là on a une belle vitrine qu'est ce qui
peut se passer quand on fait un peu
attention à sa terre bonjour moi c'est
l'aura qu'a lu je suis humoriste et
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de vous faire
découvrir mon village natal qui est dans
le var qui s'appelle coran ce qui est
très joli mais qui est surtout le
premier village entièrement biologique
de france 197 officiellement que le
vêlage est passé en agriculture
entièrement biologique c'est à dire que
tous les producteurs les viticulteurs se
sont mis à faire du bio donc un
transformé leurs terres ne plus utiliser
de produits chimiques et le village et
depuis un moment maintenant le premier
village bio de france sont ce là une
fierté
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
petit peu ce que vous faites exactement
que le travail alors nous avec dune on
fait juste vraiment tout ce qui est
travail du sol
là c'est le printemps on va nettoyer les
pieds des lignes voilà pour pas qu'elle
soit gagnée par l'ère nixon
ok on avait un premier tour camsa est en
fait tu vas après là je peux régler la
profondeur de mon outil pour régler à
quelle profondeur je veux travailler et
vraiment avec elle je peux aller soit
collée or ans à mettre au milieu
demain serbe la haute couture de la vie
ou quoi mais ce qui est génial aussi
pour moi tu vois c'est la relation tu
vois qu'on a à travailler ensemble c'est
vraiment ma collègue de travail quoi
elle est plus sympa que vous style de la
punta à cheval qu'est ce que ça change
d'un tracteur ça va vraiment se passer
dans la vie dans la vie du sol d'une
elle va beaucoup moins tu as et qu'un
tracteur va faire pour travailler
vraiment plus précisément au pied de la
ville
et bah zéro pesticide voilà d'être dans
la vraie démarche quoi ça fonctionne
fois au bureau au bio et vous à dire à
fond on est des bioman classe et c'est
la plante responsable de mes plus durs
lendemains de soirées ça c'est pour cela
qu'elle a dit non bio en viticulture je
parlais c'est le travail du sol c'est à
dire que nous on a plus de désherbants
chimiques c'est tout mécanique on va
dire nous on n'emploie pas de désherbant
chimique et on travaille notre sol alors
après il faut accepter un bios d'avoir
un peu de l'herbe
c'est sûr que l'herbe à cette époque là
et fait une concurrence à la vigne mais
quand elle est maîtrisée et gérer comme
ça ça pose aucun problème pourrait
défaire de faire du lion presse
important pourquoi parce que déjà dans
sa toxicomanie l'utilisateur en
préservant la nature pour les
générations futures
et ça je pense que c'est le plus
important et après j'avoue que quand on
sait les produits qu'on applique quand
on sait dans la bouteille ce qui a je
trouve ça génial pour le client que
c'est à dire en plus on fait un effort
pour la planète et en plus on vous
intoxiquer pas avec des produits
chimiques
on va sauver la planète si on va sauver
la place
[Musique]
là tu as toute la beauté du village
ça ça s'appelle une calade on n'emploie
pas de désherbant bien entendu est un
peu d'herbe n'a jamais fait du tort
d'accueil ça sert à rien que ce soit
trop propre
quand elle a commencé à commence le bio
est pourquoi il est enclavé toi 90
regardez pour fêter faut fêter ses 50
ans 95 tous les paysans coran sont
décidés passer en bio et disons que
c'est la première fois en france que
tout un village est en a great au bio et
depuis plus de 20 ans à une époque où
personne n'y croyait et tous les
villages de quoi rigoler de nous j'ai
été très sensibilisé au problème des
phytosanitaires et au problème des ogm
et je me suis rendu compte que les
puissances de l'argent décide et notre
avenir sans que ça nous appartient
démocratiquement et donc je trouve qu'il
ya vraiment un très trop gros problème
philosophique est donc la seule façon de
réagir à ça c'est de pas rentrer dans
leur système d'aggro agrobusiness essaie
d'apprendre d'autres voies agricole qui
respecte le monde qui respecte nos
enfants est le plus en forme
on a également
travailler sur la cantine et donc depuis
une dizaine d'années on est à peu près à
75 à 80 % bio à la cantine avant le
chaque début de repas on explique aux
enfants ce qu'ils vont manger d'où vient
la courgette ont fait des repas
végétariens bondienne très forte
pédagogie les enfants apprennent à
manger de tout et on voit que la courbe
de gaspillage est très basse à corrençon
jette moins de 10 % au niveau national
rouge et 30% un truc et le truc dont je
suis fier c'est que vous voudrions
parents d'élèves les parents me disent
ah maintenant le soir n'obligeait le
cuisiner tout ça les toilettes voilà
donc c'est là que j'ai fait mes
consommer bio c'est le jardin partagé
donc il ya une dizaine ou une quinzaine
de personnes qui ont des petits morceaux
qui cultive et tu sois des fleurs soient
des légumes
évidemment c'est absolument il respecte
l'agglo mais logique qui compostent
ensemble et du coup le partage
quand on les gens portent à leur
disposition un potager cet espace qui
est à peu près de 1500 mètres carrés est
mis gratuitement à disposition des gens
parce qu'on les cibles que les gens qui
vivent dans le village on n'a pas la
chance d'avoir des jardins et donc on
leur met gratuitement ça qu'on les
écrase
c'est trop beau
qui à 25 ans tout le monde rigolait des
grand soin et maintenant tout le monde y
avoir l'exemple ici donc je pense que
c'est en train de prendre et je pense
que les gens beaucoup de respect du
choix courageux qui a été fait ici il ya
un glissement de l'agriculture des
années intel sont impressionnantes
la moyenne d'âge des paysans encore ans
et 35 40 ans dans le var c'est 55 60
donc ici il ya vraiment une nouvelle
génération de paysans ils sont les verts
qui ont une agriculture très moderne
mécanisée mais qui ont comme principe de
faire tout pour respecter la nature ça
la philosophie du bio c'est pas d'être
dans une écriture passéiste contraire
celles agricoles demain
le grand lyon
non mais
mes poules et poulets petites poules
pondeuses
donc moi je fais des oeufs et des poules
est donc ça c'est mes petites pour ne
fondez eu forcément nourris au bio
nourrir bio terrain bio pour le bio là
ils sont semi liberté on va dire avec
des grands parcs
donc ça change des cages en industriel
alors comment tu le nourris té pou les
rires alors depuis plus en plus j'ai
fait un groupement avec d'autres
éleveurs et on fabrique notre propre
grain en achetant à les céréaliers du
coin qu'est ce que c'est donc ça c'est
l'aliment de mes poules donc là en ce
moment il ya du maïs de l'orge du soja
tourteau de sésame et les aide à faire
ça fait drôle aussi
voilà on peut parler ou commence à faire
du monde c'est surtout la superficie
d'un départ qu'à l'extérieur pour les
poulets bio il faut quatre mètres carrés
en extérieur par poulet tandis qu'un
industriel
ils sont généralement en cage donc ils
ont 80 centimètres des cages en bio on
n'a pas le droit de les abattre avant au
moins trois mois donc le poulet moyens
une fois battu on va dire prêts à cuire
il fait entre 2 kg et deux kilos et demi
voire plus sans katia comment j'attrape
si tu vas là les pattes dessous donc on
en voit là un vrai pour le bio ça
ressemble à ça donc il ya peu c'est déjà
ça dépend de quel est le coût il
appellera marché avec des pas perdus
on essaie de faire ça je me vois pas
enfermer
dans une cage c'est tellement plus sympa
quand sa cour d'or c'est compliqué de se
lancer dans le bio
aujourd'hui ça a été compliqué au niveau
des papiers ils sont pas habitués à voir
des petits élevages donc il faut remplir
des cases que je ne remplis pas
l'impression qu'on n'est pas forcément
aidé voyais pas idée du tout ni en temps
les jeunes ni en bio n'y arrive donc
c'est quand vous commencez à mettre les
pieds là dedans il faut être très très
très motivés pour pour s'installer il
faut bien s'accrocher et après ça vaut
le coup d'être là aujourd'hui de voir
tout ça ça me donne envie de mieux
consommer de moi manger de viande aussi
parce que j'ai pas envie de manger ses
poules et justement j'ai envie de manger
cette viande là les viandes en
supermarché à la chaîne les animaux qui
peuvent non plus marché entassés c'est
n'importe quoi
et donc quand quand une nana comme elle
dans son petit village décide de tenir
un projet comme celui là jusqu'au bout
sa respectable
[Musique]
on appelle ça une combinaison voilà des
piqûres d'abeilles pour pâques et
surtout les abeilles peut se prendre
dans nos cheveux aussi du coup
[Rires]
je
il
les ruches ici sur courant ça elles font
principalement du miel de romarin
voilà et du miel de bruyère à l'automne
tout est bio alors voilà tous les to
many elles sont bio l'agriculture
biologique étant donné qu'il n'y a pas
de désherbage chimique
c'est super important le désarmement
aussi a fait beaucoup de mal à l'abeille
commence c'est bien parce que le bio est
bien il oblige à garder une certaine
nature autour de soi et donc du coup
bien la belle vie dans la nature et puis
ciel nature et plus
voilà et puis ça sent heureuse bien là
j'aurai un super miel
[Musique]
on
alors j qu'est ce que tu fais tout un
courant on a ce que je fais a cours en
ce jeu propose des balades sur la
rivière donc je fais la location de
kayaks sur l'argent c'est un fleuve en
fait j'utilise les kayaks pour faire
découvrir mon mon fleuve mon endroit
on va se mettre un petit gilet ci est
donc ça chez nous oui comme la fashion
week est super c'est que moi je qui
connaît ce fleuve par coeur bat chaque
fois je redécouvre parce qu'à chaque
fois ça y est ça change ça ça bouge
qu'est-ce qui peut remarquer en 20 ans
devient comme changement il eu pas mal
de changements au niveau de la de la
faune et la flore c'est vrai qu'on avait
une différence assez énorme
est ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
on est passé en bio au niveau des mois
je vais parler surtout la rivière on a
on sait intéresser un peu à ce qui
arrive est de plus haut et lens aperçu
il ya 20 ans est l'un peut déroger
quittez pas très propre
donc ça on a fait savoir les vins
travail très important à ce niveau là et
du coup on a un fleuve qui arrive qui
très propre
aujourd'hui plus d'animaux plus animée
exactement
alors on voit sur l'aviron va en
principe pas les plus beaux on va voir
les martins-pêcheurs signifie qu'on va
voir des héros durant sans dred airport
on va trouver des canards des poules
d'eau des ragondins et les bras qualité
et de laura cadieux rien c'est un gage
de pureté nortene des chats qui viennent
décollé juste la fois le héros avait
adressé à l'essai des lentilles d'eau
moi quand j'étais gamin ici il y avait
peut-être 2,3 algues est différente on
aurait pas tant que ça et là maintenant
on est peut-être facilement une dizaine
de dates différentes
s'il y avait une seule a colonisé tous
là on pourrait commencer à s'inquiéter
donc c'est une façon aussi de surveiller
la qualité de l'eau depuis qu'on est pas
sans murs bon penser par soi-même d'une
différence c'est que les pesticides les
herbicides infinie c'est dans la rivière
donc que toutes ces âmes n'existait pas
parce qu'ils ont été tués par tous ces
produits finis donc c'est vrai qu'on
voit une réelle différence on a un
papillon qui avait disparu qui sait
qu'il est complètement disparu on va
différencier des fleurs qui avait
complètement disparu au dessus comme ça
q c'est ouais donc j'ai pas vu mon
enfance exactement faire grandir ses
enfants dans un environnement comme ça
c'est quelque chose d'assez magique
d'assez d'assez précieux donc c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de petites familles
qui vient de s'installer pour que les
enfants grandissent dans ce dans ce
havre de paix que son petit coin de
paradis où on n'est pas trop embêté par
la pollution où on peut manger des
choses saines et ça s'encourage beaucoup
de gens qui habitent ici ici ici en
blanc moi j'en profite justement on fait
beaucoup d'éducation parce qu'ici on a
la matière a montré que la nature
reprendre sa place
elle reprend ses droits on la bim-sa
c'est sûr mais c'est nous qui allons le
payer c'est pas forcément la nature la
nature
elle reviendra
c'est important pour moi de montrer la
rivière de l'argent c'est de faire cette
balade en canoë avec julien et il
m'avait vraiment fait prendre conscience
de l'évolution du village de la forêt du
verre quand on fait cette balade en
rivière on se rend compte que ça a
changé énormément que ça a évolué il ya
bien plus de végétation
il ya beaucoup de poissons d'animaux
d'insectes et pourtant j'aime pas trop
les insectes mais ici les accepte pas ce
que me dit mais non c'est tellement
normal qu'ils aient des insectes c'est
qu'il ya la vie quand on voit dans
l'autre toutes ces plantes vertes dans
l'eau qui pousse dans l'eau il y en
avait pas quand j'étais petit déjà fait
je suis fier de voir tous ces gens tous
les habitants du village tenir tenir
leurs engagements envers envers la
planète
ici ça me donne de l'espoir je me dis
mais si en fait c'est possible en fait
ça marche quand on fait attention à la
planète il ya vraiment du changement
mais en fait on n'est pas foutu mais ça
donne envie toute cette verdure
comment tu peux pas avoir envie et en
plus si c'est faisable et vous comment
d'une va dire j'ai envie de faire ça moi
aussi
et ce qui est frappant c'est que c'est
possible
et ici bas ça prouve que celle tout
simplement
je